спочатку п'яту рейсі шлях йому з коржею
занесе його і закону дав закріпив це
так дзвоню презумпції правоти
поліцейського виступив міністр внутрішніх
справа україни арсен аваків якщо а то
лайк за стріли двох поліцейських вин
посла вся на той світ рожевий на них
святого їх демократію за роликом і до них
великий назвав не машину у team ціни за
всіма від бачить дієвості
Една в німецькому законі чітко прописано
заїка їх обставлений їжу цих заходи в
може вдаватися синематики поліцейські
саду ж видозмінюється за важливо
ситуації алайка ідеальну хвали на кшт
old поліцейський завжди правий і особливо
чоловікові і в цьому не менше не і ціни ви
тремоло джона та правової та перевірка їх
шушу український владос правді хоч під
бата прірва pq поліцейських тому стати
під ботана сам парад правий соку
професіонал свиту поліцейських народити
експерти та дайте про спеціальні
тренінги для дружних патрулі fda на вч
адже я як правильно восени water мова та
і по 2 ти про свою, оскільки на вітрило
краще правлю ден і в нього че не такий
анапчани відриваєшся найменше 3 року і
з виглядом це ще розуміння істот
презумпції правоти поліцейського зробити
він внаслідок я є у міністра внутрішніх straus
а з боготи річковою практикою і самої з я
гадаю проблема в Україні
німецької експорту перуку він не за я
вам і з розумним і закону давши чому хвалово
а владним ідеям і поліція мусою до
висоти хз встиг ства що ванадію
правомірно
і поліцейські мають бути самі хлопці що
їх не є правовим і
і в кожному украм йому випад cute new в
це вигляд побачити своїх де сама cl праву
і державан чайного живу за родом
нову роботу поліцейських та травня за води
ти державному зловили п'яний amnesty
international рекомендую українську
володар дистанціюватиме собі задушливих заяв
вовк рим зрощення насильства tonari
кінця укус usb листя ви не скуті
дадуть
до того ж в українських ролях на б спиць
там не пабу його не що тугу чого не до
поліцейського держави
продати шева свою годину вирішу що виступи
у майдан